this scene is about three quarters of
the way into the film
martha and her mother um
for the first time after a couple of
months and the whole family
is brought together for a supposed
dinner and
tensions are at breaking point elizabeth
played by ellen tells martha for the
first time that
her cousin is going to be the lawyer on
the case that she's been driving
to convict the midwife who she feels is
responsible for the death of martha's
baby
and so this is the beginning of a a
confrontation that has probably been
bubbling for about
four or five months what are we even
doing here this is completely nuts what
the [ __ ]
well as long as you're asking
um suzanne
i've consulted with her about the about
the case
you're the prosecutor on the case yes
she's a
she's an excellent lawyer and she's
family
you know she she loves us she's here to
make sure we get the right thing look
the case is already won people hate this
woman
so i'm just yes exactly
and i don't want them to judge you them
people people by people
people you mean judith i mean judy [ __ ]
off chris [ __ ] off
because if you're talking about judith i
went to a store to get an apple 20
minutes later i am in the same store
getting the same apple i know that
exactly because i met him late i met you
how late 25 minutes i spent a minute
getting an apple maybe a minute of the
frozen section the rest of the time i
spent there stuck
stranded getting grilled by your friend
trying to figure out what the [ __ ] she
wants from me
are you worried about them judging me
martha
i remember after the very first take of
the birth i know you and i
talked about this i ended up my body was
like really crying for 10 minutes and
cornell held me he just said remember
this feeling this is the thing that's
really going on inside martha
even when she's not showing it and so i
sort of tried to bottle that
up and then for the rest of the the
shoot keep that inside but not show it
and then i
knew that this scene coming up that that
what
what i tried to sort of keep in was
going to come out and then of course
it made so much sense that it was
between mother and daughter because
the people that you love most and the
people you're closest to are often
the ones where you do really release
them
in some ways she's a very easy person to
love
she's as you can see smart and charming
and funny
and dear and talented so
to be her mother was a was easy
and a wonderful feeling you know and
it's not even about them judging me
actually it's about
it's about how you want me to be to fit
their opinion to you want to arrange me
you need therapy i do not need therapy
thank you
all right [ __ ] who cares about what
they think this is about me this is
about my body
this is me do you understand that yes i
understand that
we didn't know what the second half of
the scene was actually gonna look like
the argument do you remember so
we weren't you know we were shooting
that i think the following week maybe
and we were still working out what they
were going to
say to each other exactly because it
kept evolving because nothing felt
true in our profession you worry so much
about not fulfilling something
and then you go to do it and
something comes through that you
couldn't possibly have
designed you know ahead of time whatever
it was i didn't know
what point in the scene it would be or
really how it would be expressed but i
knew that the lid would come off
um and it was important to do that have
you decided to go to the trial
i'm not going to your [ __ ] trial why
not honey
she has to pay for her incompetence is
this about money no
is it is it about what what people think
it's about you
it's about you having to face i am
facing this i am
facing it i am facing this well
i don't think you are we need
we need some justice here no you need
that is what you want that is what you
need that is
that is your way that is not my way that
is what you need
martha if you had done it my way you'd
be holding your
baby in your arms right now it's not a
line i would have said which is always
an
interesting moment when you suddenly
realize there's a space between you and
your character
that you have to leap over when pushed
she's almost like i always felt like she
was a bit of a and a caged animal her
secret of her shame is so great that
it's always a moment away of
from coming out i mean all the way
through the film you're
so bottled up you know after the
the death of the child you were decaying
inside
from keeping it inside
and that you needed to
shout cry scream i don't care what say
talk
but get it out i felt that you
disappointed me and then we all knew we
had to go much further than that and it
had to be something
so much more painful and
true you're ashamed you are
so ashamed of me you're ashamed because
i failed
oh what a disgrace oh what a disgrace
i failed yeah you're [ __ ] ashamed
and i'm ashamed of me that i wasn't a
good enough mother to
teach you how to stand up and speak for
yourself for god's sakes
and to deal with this like my mother
taught me
after my father went into the ghetto my
my mother found a shack
an empty shack that she went into and
gave birth to me
without any help at all she stashed me
under the floorboards
when she had to go out and steal
food so she could make milk enough to
keep me alive
but just alive not strong enough to cry
or would be caught
when she finally got me to a doctor he
advised her to just
let me go that i wasn't
i wasn't strong enough to survive
but when she absolutely insisted
he picked me up by my feet and held me
up like a
chicken and said if she tries to lift
her head
then there's hope
and you know what i did mother
i lifted my head that's what i'm asking
you to do now
lift your head and fight for yourself
for god's sakes
go out there and face that woman tell
her what it's like for you now
what this feels like you
have to do this mother you have to speak
your truth
otherwise you're never going to be able
to deal with this
you're never going to be able to move on
you've got to move on past this mother
you just ripped into it i think
that the lines that came out of me at
the end
that you have to you have to own it you
have to state your feelings you have to
get it out you have to say
how this is for you i've also thought
since
how hard that speech is to why why would
a mother just
suddenly recount the story when she was
born to her daughter and you think has
she not done that before has she
brought that story up before has she
ever why now and you just made it like a
kind of
a cry of pain i mean it's so funny
because us two together we're so cozy
with each other aren't we
and yet martha and elizabeth are really
cold really really cold
their reaction to pain i think is
coldness and
austere you know
um getting up and getting on with it
really
um and i mean
you have to really trust another actor
to do that and
i'm so honored to say that you know i
felt like you trusted me
and um i was
i was very led by you and
i enjoyed it so much me too